après deux mois de silence les écoles
s'apprête à reprendre vie des milliers
d'élèves ont retrouvé un décor bien
connu mais découvrir une réalité qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec celle qu'ils ont
laissées derrière le 13 mars dernier
comme des retrouvailles
la première leçon de madame marie
michèle et déjà décidé ce sera
l'apprentissage des nouvelles consignes
un nouveau mode c'est nouveau pour te
ment on va s'ajuster classes réduites
désinfectant nouvelles règles des
déplacements dans les corridors il a
fallu en deux semaines organisé les
lieux accueillant mais aussi sécuritaire
un véritable casse tête
avant on entrait 72 élèves dans un
autobus puis maintenant 20 ans très
douce
la commission scolaire des navigateurs
atteindre tour de 72% de ses élèves sur
tout son territoire
chaque groupe devra demeurer dans son
local en tout temps l'école ça sera un
peu différent parce qu'ils vont rentrer
dans leur local ils vont dîner dans leur
local et après ça ils vont faire le
service de garde dans leur local
seulement autorisé à l'extérieur les
récréations elle non plus n'auront rien
à voir avec celle d'avant notre cour a
été partagé en zone 6 secondes et il y
aura à la fois ci ce groupe à
l'extérieur en beauce la polyvalente
benoît-vachon va héberger 22 classes
d'élèves du primaire
certains profs ont trouvé une façon
originale de préparer leurs élèves à la
rentrée
une manière de dédramatiser la situation
qui n'empêche pas de se préparer à toute
éventualité
si jamais un 4 e vide se déclare le
sarrau et on doit mettre aussi une
visière
cette rentrée sera particulière à bien
des égards pour une rare fois l'école
les enseignants devons apprendre autant
que leurs élèves ici sébastien tanguy
radio canada québec